[Musique]
bonsoir les amis petit louis et mirabel
ont l'air très sage ce soir j'ai bien
l'impression qu'ils sont déjà couché
debout me méfie de ces deux petits
galopins ne fait pas trop de bruit pour
ne pas les réveiller
on ne veut pas pas trop bon ce brol les
enfants tu sais qu'on joue on a des
merveilles oui on a un coffre à
merveille à cette voie là ouais on va te
le montrer mais mais tout vient qu il
était dans le grenier et maintenant il
est sous le lit les biens mirabel on va
le chercher puis qu'on va le chercher
quelques pistes à l'étude hier par la
coûteuse si difficile c'est de la
poussette et tu prends le poney mirabel
ça y est c'est qu'est ce que la wii 2 et
3 à l'essayer cola company ou là ou là
ne lâche pas mirobolant s'ils ont reçu
oui mais attention qu'ils ont envers son
temps surtout à bien là allez on le
pousse sur la tâche à bien
ben voilà ça y est déjà vers bigrement
lourd qu'est ce qu'il y a deux dents que
c'est beau tu fais mais s'il ya tant de
merveilles
peut-être bien qu'au fond il y à un pot
de miel est drôlement gourmand non merci
c'était d'y apporter à la jolie coquille
à leur écoute le moose preuve
mais mais oui on entend la mer écoute
mirabel
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
voyons voir est ce que dans ce coin et
il n'y aurait pas par hasard un petit
podium douce et des bijoux c'est pas du
miel au haut des bras cela il ça qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un tien des médias
guy bessette va très bien
c'est vrai je suis bon
oui on dirait roi des rois comme le roi
dagobert
[Musique]
voilà pas nouveau j'ai envie qu'ils cruz
ou km vous fera du théâtre rue est un
théâtre on chante d'accord et maintenant
d'orbites car il est à revoir voilà une
annonce ça qui lui on sent les rebelles
[Musique]
il ment
mirabel bonne nuit petit louis vos nuits
tous les enfants en temps mais vous vite
nous reviendrons vous voir demain
allons le roi dagobert en route bonne
nuit
bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh